Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show.
I'm producer Pat Forde, filling in for David
today.
He is on vacation and will be back at the
end of the week in response to the mass shooting
that took place in Tennessee a couple of weeks
back.
Republicans who are in control of the state
legislature have decided to take action, but
not in any sort of substantive way, not by
strengthening background checks or banning
certain types of weapons.
Instead, they've decided to expel two members
of the legislative body who took part in the
protest and essentially broke the rules of
decorum in the legislative body in so doing.
Tennessee lawmakers expelled two members from
the state legislature just to Jones and Justin
Peterson after they and a third member, Gloria
Johnson, took part in a protest against gun
violence from the floor of the chamber.
The vote took place last Thursday with Johnson
surviving expulsion by only a single vote.
Notably, Jones and Pierson are black, whereas
Johnson, the one who survived the expulsion
vote, is white.
I'll leave it up to you to decide whether
that has anything to do with the results.
Following the mass shooting, there was a protest
at the legislative chamber to try to get lawmakers
to do anything at all about this issue of
gun violence and using their position as representatives
to be actually inside the House chamber.
These three lawmakers used a bullhorn and
temporarily disrupted the official business
of the legislative body, leading the Republican
supermajority to call for a recess.
Let's take a look at some of the video of
the protests taking place.
We have heard.
Speaker 3: A lot about.
Unidentified: Thank you.
You are being heard.
Speaker 1: Now, after this happened, Republicans
who hold a large majority of seats immediately
pledged a rapid response.
They stripped Johnson and Jones of committee
assignments.
I don't believe Pierson yet had any committee
Motions to expel the three from the legislature
were introduced by three different members
of the state legislature on April 3rd, accusing
the trio of disorderly behavior.
Now, to put this in context, it's very rare
for expulsions to take place in the Tennessee
legislature.
Just eight lawmakers have been expelled from
the House in the state's history.
Six of those were confederates who were expelled
in the 19th century for refusing to affirm
the citizenship of formerly enslaved black
people.
In the 20th century, a legislator was expelled
after being convicted of bribery, and most
recently in 2016, a member was expelled for
sexual misconduct.
So this expulsion wasn't really about the
merits.
It only happened because Republicans had the
votes to be able to do it, and they took advantage
of that.
And in fact, Justin Jones, one of the two
ousted members, highlighted in a speech that
he gave on the floor, some of the things that
his fellow members of the legislature did
over the years, or at least were accused of
doing that, did ultimately not result in an
expulsion.
Let's take a look at him talking about that.
Speaker 4: Let's talk about expulsion.
For years, One of your colleagues who was
admitted child molester sat in this chamber.
No expulsion.
One member sits in this chamber who was found
guilty of domestic violence.
No expulsion.
We had a former speaker sits in this chamber
who is now under federal investigation.
No expulsion.
We have a member still under federal investigation.
We had a member P in another member's chair
in this chamber.
No expulsion.
In fact, they're in leadership now.
Speaker 1: The hope is that from a political
standpoint, this will backfire on Republicans,
because not only has this brought the issue
of gun violence more to the forefront and
how members of Congress at the state and federal
level aren't really doing anything about it.
It's also made these three national figures,
the Tennessee three, as they're now being
called.
Vice President Kamala Harris visited the lawmakers
in Nashville on Friday, and President Biden
also spoke with the three via conference call
inviting them to visit the White House.
Now, to be clear, I don't know if disrupting
proceedings and using a bullhorn is the right
way to go about protesting this sort of matter,
despite it being peaceful, of course, and
despite it being clearly intended to only
being to be a temporary disruption.
And that's because if, let's say the shoe
was on the other foot, let's say, you know,
at the Capitol, we saw Marjorie Taylor GREENE
and Lauren Boebert do this exact same thing
on one of the issues that they care about.
Would we be totally fine with it?
I'm not sure.
I just want to stay consistent on this.
Right.
Nevertheless, I think that expulsion would
be way too extreme if that was to take place.
I think the most appropriate thing to do in
that sort of instance would be maybe a censure.
Right.
Because these people were duly elected to
represent their constituents.
And barring some sort of extreme event, they
should be able to serve out their term.
So I think censuring them, which is basically
just an official condemnation, would have
made a lot more sense for something like this,
breaking the rules of decorum.
But Republicans in this situation, they were
just trying to abuse their power and be vindictive
on this matter.
And then final point I want to make on this.
Some on the right are comparing this to January
6th, when there's absolutely no comparison
to be drawn here to the Capitol insurrection.
On that day, January six, 2021, we saw rioters
beating up cops.
We saw the Senate chamber get overtaken.
We saw several people die.
Based on, you know, because of what happened,
it was directed and then not put a stop to
by the then president of the United States.
And the intent of the protests that became
a riot was to overthrow the government, to
end democracy in the United States.
This, on the other hand, was a peaceful protest
That was yeah, sure, at times a little rowdy.
But there was no intention of overthrowing
the government.
There was no clear acts of violence.
And it was not intended to end democracy in
the state of Tennessee.
So spare me those comparisons.
It will be interesting to see what happens
next.
And Pierson and Jones, the two who were expelled
from the legislature, will be able to run
for their seats again.
Let's hope that they're able to win back their
seats and then all will be good.